after striking a new military-based deal
in the Philippines the U.S is making
moves to counter China's growing
militarization of the Pacific China's
military buildup IS astonishing to some
it's impressive and it's not showing any
signs of slowing down it's not showing
any signs of slowing down
these troops trained for a potential
conflict on Islands just a hundred miles
from Taiwan the self-ruled island that
China has threatened to take by force if
necessary
and Powerful American weapons were
tested over the South China Sea where
China's militarized islands are
threatening its neighbors what the U.S
is doing now we wish it did
but after more than 20 years of Chinese
expansion can the U.S and its allies
successfully change the balance of power
in the Pacific
the Philippines a U.S treaty Ally lies
Southeast of mainland China to its West
is the South China Sea a global Shipping
route full of natural resources and to
the north is Taiwan a key U.S trading
partner Beijing says both Taiwan and
much of the sea are part of China and
has ramped up its military presence to
bolster those claims already with a
continued publication from China
as concerned as you could possibly be
it is one of the major issues that we
have to face the Philippines new
president Ferdinand bongbong Marcos Jr
has leaned into the U.S after years of a
more pro-china policy under his
predecessor Rodrigo duterte this year
Washington and Manila struck a major
base deal that increased the number of
sites the U.S can use in the Philippines
from five to nine under the enhanced
defense cooperation agreement the new
sites bring the U.S military closer to
both Taiwan and the South China Sea and
the deal allows the U.S to build
facilities position equipment and rotate
troops through the bases
the new sites have angered China which
has accused the US of intentionally
stoking Regional tensions one of the
phrases that I've heard is the U.S could
use these bases as staging grounds
against China is that what they are I
think you could feasibly see that they
are but
we wouldn't do any of that without the
consent of the Philippine government
China is a free and Sovereign Nation and
as long as they act within the
international based rules-based order
here in the region they have plenty of
room to operate Major General Joseph
Ryan commands the Army's 25th Infantry
Division we met him on the USS Miguel
Keith in the Luzon Street the Luzon
Strait is a strategic Waterway that's a
major commercial shipping Lane and a key
Transit point for both the Chinese and
U.S militaries in the event of a
conflict over Taiwan control of the
strait would be critical
Chinese exercises in and around the
Strait have heightened concerns about a
war in the region and because the U.S
and the Philippines have a mutual
defense treaty the U.S would be
obligated to defend the country if it's
attacked geography matters there's
certainly a sense that should conflict
occur in Taiwan that the Philippines
would be
affected is the U.S prepared to fight
absolutely and that's what we're doing
here
we followed Major General Ryan in his
joint unit onto Marine Ospreys and
traveled to some of the northernmost
islands in the Philippines
the objective of the drill to secure the
area and then expand it making room for
even bigger Firepower like this High
Mars an offensive weapon system that's
capable of reaching the southern part of
Taiwan from this island the highmore's
rocket system on the island here could
certainly influence not only the land
space but the maritime space
[Music]
not just where it sits here on Bosco
Island along the coast of the South
China Sea the U.S and Philippine
militaries conducted live fires of the
highmars and other Advanced American
weapons like stingers and Patriots
marking a major escalation of the
exercises from years past
[Applause]
for years Beijing has used this
so-called nine-dash line to roughly
outline what it says belongs to China
the dashes are believed to be based on
maps used by the Republic of China in
1947. within those lines these satellite
images show how China has turned reefs
into artificial islands and added
airstrips missile silos and
communication towers that offends
Filipinos it's like you you always have
a dagger appointed towards here General
Emanuel Bautista became the chief staff
of the Philippine armed forces in 2013
the year the Philippines took China to
court over its contested claims the
Philippines won the landmark case but
China has refused to recognize the
ruling to maintain control its ships
have repeatedly harassed its neighbors
Coast Guard vessels and civilian fishing
boats blocking their passage with larger
ships military-grade lasers and even
water cannons China is violating our
sovereignty and Sovereign rights and
regardless of there is a competition we
have an issue in China in that respect
polls show most Filipinos support
stronger ties with the U.S to help the
country defend its sovereignty and
despite China's warnings not to
interfere in the South China Sea the
country is in talks with the U.S and
other Pacific allies like Japan to
launch joint patrols later this year our
goal is peace security stability
creating opportunity it's not to engage
in a new Cold War it's not to contain
China some experts say it might be too
late to change the balance of power in
the region China now has more naval
ships more ICBM launchers more active
service members and potentially more
sophisticated missile capabilities than
the us but the U.S is counting on its
alliances in the Pacific to push back
and in recent months Washington has
increased security ties with Japan
Australia and South Korea and it has
pledged to expedite weapon sales to
Taiwan the asymmetric advantage of our
alliances and Partnerships in the region
is part of what separates us from the
PRC because they don't have that the
relationships they don't have the
relationships combat credible forces
Allied and together
win Wars so if conflict happens I'm
confident we're prepared to fight it
foreign